first of all tell me about this look
girl thank you forgot about it was
actually one of my Christmas presents
from Kanye for Christmas this year he
bought you a couture gown for Christmas
yes Alexander McQueen 2003 it's a
shipwreck dress so I would always stress
out about big events like this and what
would I wear and the last-minute part of
it and so he kind of filled it up and
got me a few really nice couture pieces
so that I wouldn't stress out like that
okay that's a nice life to have are
there any secrets about this I can
hardly move yes that's about it did you
guys get a chance to watch it all while
you were getting ready and did you was
there a moment that stood out to you you
had semanas seeing people I mean Eminem
watching him perform was really really
cool I mean it was fun to see everyone
in the audience know all the words and
just really have a good time with that
and Brad Pitt winning I know I know
oh man you know upon a time in Hawley is
so deserving I want to ask you I know
that you're the biggest thing on social
media do you see do you ever tick-tock I
do
North has a private tick-tock account so
we do lots of tick-tocks
together and she puts them in drafts
she's not allowed to post them but we
have lots of tick tocks I might post one
soon I think
now now that I have you guys together is
this a good time for me to remind you
that Kanye owes me 150 dollars for his
music video in Brooklyn do you remember
who told me that
it's okay I'm gonna let's let it go now
we'll let it go now okay thank you for
the interview it was wonderful to see
you
I'm calling us cash balance zero okay
[Music]